To do incremental visual tracking
using principal component analysis,
what we want to do is you want to build
a tracker that is not just based upon
a single patch but sort of constantly
update some form of a model.
between me and you, that model is
going to be a basis set, so were
going to keep changing the basis set
a little bit as the, as the model moves.
We want something that runs quickly and
can operate even if
the camera is moving.
And, of course, the,
the general challenge here is,
we would like this thing to be able
to handle if the pose is changing, so
how the thing is moving,
you know, rotating, translating.
Maybe parts of it get occluded, okay?
And we'll talk about how to
handle occlusion in just a bit.
You have illumination change.
And you want to avoid drift, that is,
you don't want to start, you know,
tracking someone's face and all of a
sudden you realize you're just tracking
the bottom half of the face and then
it just gets stuck on a file cabinet.
Right, you want to stick to their face.
So the paper that some of this is pulled
from is this incremental learning for
robust visual tracking.
And I'm just using this.
I mean it's, it's,
at this point known well.
And also, it gives you a sense of how
to use principle component analysis,
which we just learned,
particle filtering,
which you know,
in order to do incremental tracking.
This doesn't really belong
in the recognition unit, but
since we couldn't do it until
you knew about PCA, here it is.
So here are the main ideas, all right?
First, we are going to use some
form of a particle filter, but
the particle,
are going to represent the deformation.
And the deformation may mean just an a
fine that is six degrees of freedom.
It could be similarity,
it could even be just translation.
But the idea is that the particles
are going to capture
how the geometry changes
from frame to frame.
The second main idea is that, we're
going to use the subspace method that I
talked before about, detection, right?
So, the idea is that we have some small
set of eigen vectors, they can reproduce
only images that kind of look like
some thing that comes from this class.
And we're going to use that
subspace in order to say, ha!
That's a good example of
the thing I'm tracking,
because I can reconstruct
that image really well.
The third thing,
which is kind of the new, new and
cool part is,
that we don't fix the subspace.
We let it change incrementally as we
get new it, so we, we track this image,
we track this object, we bring in
the new image and we might say, oh.
Maybe it's changed a little bit.
Let me change my subspace
just a little bit.
So by changing my subspace a little bit,
I can track changes in appearance but
it's because it's an entire subspace.
I don't get fooled by a sort of small
variation that's just local in time.
And I can sort of hang on to the object.
You'll see an example of
that as we go forward.